[Musica]
il paradiso un luogo
idillico dove Regnano pace Armonia
perfezione e
serenità Un concetto spesso associato a
un contesto religioso un qualcosa di
sovrannaturale e che non appartiene alla
sfera della realtà nella quale Noi
viviamo esiste Però anche un altro
concetto di paradiso ossia quello del
paradiso
terrestre questo è composto dagli
ecosistemi che ci circondano dalle
creature che li abitano le stesse
creature che ci forniscono l'ossigeno
che respiriamo l'energia
grazie alla quale ci muoviamo e compiamo
le nostre azioni quotidiane e anche le
materie prime grazie alle quali
produciamo e realizziamo le nostre
tecnologie ma non è tutto perché queste
creature sono anche una fonte
inesauribile di
ispirazione soltanto che noi specie
umana non avevamo mai prestato loro la
sufficiente
attenzione fino ad ora
la biomimesi Infatti letteralmente
tradotta in innovazione ispirata dalla
natura è una disciplina che studia come
appunto noi specie umana possiamo
prendere a modello le forme naturali i
processi biologici o il funzionamento di
alcuni ecosistemi per realizzare le
nostre tecnologie tecnologie che non
siano solo più sostenibili ma anche più
efficienti Infatti pensate che nei
nostri processi produttivi attualmente
utilizziamo ogni singolo elemento
all'interno della tavola periodica anche
quelli più pericolosi e tossici
combinandoli o scendi in reazioni che
definirei brutali dato il loro Altissimo
consumo energetico in natura invece
viene utilizzata solo una piccola fetta
di questi elementi quelli più sicuri e
meno tossici
combinandoli e scindendo in delle
reazioni che al contrario definirei
eleganti a basso consumo energetico a
bassa temperatura a bassa tossicità ma
soprattutto senza mai produrre scarti
che non possono essere riutilizzati o
che vadano ad inquinare l'ambiente
circostante la natura Dunque ci ispira
ma in quali settori Quali sono gli
ambiti nei quali la natura ispira le
innovazioni che più si adattano ai
nostri usi vi faccio qualche esempio
prendiamo gli
squali cosa sappiamo di loro sono degli
efficienti predatori e anche degli
straordinari protettori dei nostri Mari
quello che non sapevamo però è che
questi animali sono in grado di ispirare
l'innovazione in ambito sanitario Ebbene
sì perché lo studio della pelle del
grande squalo bianco ha portato alla
realizzazione di nuove superfici
antibatteriche applicabili appunto in
ambienti
ospedalieri infatti la pelle che ricopre
il grande squalo bianco è composta da
migliaia di scaglie chiamate In termine
tecnico denticoli dermici queste scaglie
hanno una forma particolare ricoperte di
pieghe e scanalature che permettono di
generare il minor attrito possibile tra
la superficie della pelle dello squalo e
e l'acqua Quindi il fluido all'interno
del quale esso si muove e caccia le sue
prede permettendogli di essere un
fenomenale predatore in ambienti Marini
ma non è tutto perché la forma di queste
scaglie permette anche ai impedisce ai
microrganismi in particolare ai batteri
di potersi depositare e quindi
proliferare sulla superficie dello
squalo essi Infatti si vedono costretti
a staccarsi e a trovare un'altra
superficie sulla quale moltiplicarsi
lasciando la pelle dello squalo
Completamente priva di
impurità questa strategia è stata
immediatamente d'ispirazione per
scienziati e ricercatori che hanno
deciso di realizzare una superficie
artificiale sulla quale hanno stampato
in 3D
una superficie Appunto una trama che
imitasse la forma di queste scaglie con
pieghe scanalature per impedire ai
batteri di depositarsi senza però
utilizzare antibiotici o veleni per
ucciderli hanno realizzato questa
superficie su sottilissimi fogli adesivi
da applicare sulle superfici che
necessitano di rimanere sterili o su
quelle dove più spesso avviene il
contagio di germi o batteri quindi i
corrimani le maniglie delle porte o
all'interno delle sale operatorie stesse
o sugli stessi strumenti chirurgici Ma
non è tutto perché questa strategia è
stata anche applicata su oggetti di uso
comune come le cover dei nostri
cellulari o le tastiere dei nostri
computer ma la natura ispira
l'innovazione anche e soprattutto in
ambienti
estremi come il
deserto quello che vedete dietro di me
si chiama coleottero delle nebbie è un
piccolo insetto che vive in uno degli AB
abitat più aridi al mondo il deserto del
namib in Africa l'aridità di questo
luogo Tuttavia è interrotta di tanto in
tanto da una fitta nebbia che attraversa
il deserto e questo piccolo insetto sa
benissimo come sfruttare questa rara
occasione Infatti comincia a correre e
arrampicarsi fin sulla cima delle dune e
una volta raggiunta solleva la parte
posteriore del suo corpo che presenta
delle micr ciche protuberanze che
agiscono come dei magneti per l'acqua
catturando le microscopiche particelle
che si accumuleranno sulla corazza
dell'insetto e per gravità man mano
scivoleranno verso la sua bocca disset
andolo questa tecnologia ha subito
ispirato diversi gruppi di ricercatori
che hanno sviluppato delle reti cattura
nebbia si tratta di reti metalliche che
imitano nella trama lo stesso motivo a
protuberanze che caratterizza la corazza
dell'insetto catturando una quantità
d'acqua sufficiente Non solo a garantire
acqua potabile per le popolazioni che
vivono in ambienti aridi o isolati ma
anche sufficiente per poter garantire
loro di coltivare ed allevare bestiame
una vera e propria rivoluzione per
queste
popolazioni ma non è tutto perché questa
strategia può essere applicata anche in
altri ambiti come per esempio nella
realizzazione di tende cattura nebbia
per campi d'accoglienza di emergenza
oppure su bottiglie borracce in grado di
riempirsi in autonomia o anche su Chissà
che in futuro le nostre città o la
nostra stessa casa sarà realizzata con
mura o tegole in grado di catturare
l'acqua Che utilizzeremo nella nostra
vita quotidiana per dissetarsi per bere
appunto per cucinare o per dar da bere
alle nostre
piante l'ultimo esempio che vi porto
infine è anche il mio preferito e viene
dal campo della robotica e dei
software quella che vedete dietro di me
si Chama Fisar
polium un nome molto difficile Infatti
per gli amici viene chiamata muffa
melmosa
è una creatura straordinaria e pensate
che essa non è né un animale né una
pianta ma non è tantomeno un fungo e
nemmeno un batterio è un
protista un microscopico organismo
unicellulare che vive al confine tra lo
stato liquido e quello solido è una
creatura molto antica Infatti è presente
sulla terra da 600 milioni di anni e si
muove nell'ambiente circostante
alternando pulsazioni e contrazioni
andando alla ricerca di segnali chimici
che per lei significano
cibo ma non è l'unico aspetto
straordinario di questa muffa Essa
infatti può essere definita a tutti gli
effetti intelligente essa è in grado
infatti di raggiungere le fonti di
nutrimento sempre nella maniera più
efficace possibile sempre consumando
minor quantitativo di energia a sua
disposizione ma non solo perché questa
muffa ha anche una memoria è in grado
infatti di ricordare tutti quegli
avvenimenti che avvengono in maniera
ciclica nell'ambiente nella quale essa
si trova come per esempio il cambio
delle stagioni e adatta Il suo
metabolismo e il suo comportamento di
conseguenza gli scienziati hanno voluto
studiare il comportamento di questa
muffa e un gruppo di Scienziati
giapponesi in particolare ha condotto
uno studio su diessa che è passato alla
storia questo gruppo di Scienziati
Infatti ha deciso di prendere una
piastra di dimensioni definite
quadrata posizionando su questa piastra
dei piccoli chicchi D'Avena che per la
muffa sono fonte di cibo hanno poi
posizionato la muffa stessa al centro
della piastra per monitorarne il comport
dopo poche ore vediamo che la nostra
muffa melmosa comincia a esplorare
l'ambiente circostante e cercare di
capire dove sono le fonti di nutrimento
Quanto sono distanti da lei e quali E
quante
sono dopo un poco più di un giorno ha
già completato la sua colonizzazione ha
già esplorato e assorbito tutti i
nutrienti lasciando Però dietro di sé
solo quelle connessioni che le
permettevano di raggiungere non solo il
primo Chicco d'Avena a sua disposizione
ma anche tutti quelli successivi in
qualsiasi
direzione voi Mi direte va bene È un
esperimento interessante ma niente di
straordinario a mio avviso gli
scienziati sapevano che la muffa si
sarebbe comportata o si comportava così
già in natura quindi sapevano che si
sarebbe comportato così anche in
laboratorio interessante dal punto di
vista scientifico ma non mi
sorprende l'aspetto straordinario di
questo esperimento è che gli scienziati
hanno posizionato la muffa al centro
della piastra simulando l'esatta
posizione geografica della città di
Tokyo in
Giappone mentre tutti i chicchi D'Avena
attorno posizionati sulla piastra
rappresentano la posizione geografica di
tutte le città della linea metropolitana
connessa a Tokyo stessa avete capito la
nostra muffa melmosa era stata in grado
in poco più di 24 ore di ricreare
l'esatta struttura della rete
metropolitana che collega Tokyo a tutte
le città
circostanti un problema di progettazione
che aveva tenuto impegnati scienziati
ingegneri progettatori civili e
costruttori per quasi un secolo risolta
in poco più di un giorno da un semplice
organismo
unicellulare un computer biologico
microscopico che gli scienziati stanno
cercando di decodificare e estrapolare
da essa modelli matematici o algoritmi
in grado di essere applicati alle nostre
stesse tecnologie realizzando
innovazioni impensabili fino ad ora come
reti elettriche Intelligenti in grado di
ripararsi in autonomia aeroplani o
automobili in grado di pilotari da soli
o ancora robot di nuova
generazione non più solo metallici
questa volta ma Soffici
flessibili così microscopici da essere
in grado di entrare all'interno del
nostro stesso organismo è in grado di
identificare ed eliminare le cellule
tumorali e le metastasi ancor prima che
qualsiasi metodo di diagnosi sviluppato
dall'uomo sia in grado di
individuarle ingegneria medicina design
robotica
biotecnologie gli ambiti di applicazione
della biomimesi sono infiniti così come
sono infinite infiniti gli esempi che
potrei portare AR VII oggi ma tutte
queste strategie per quanto differenti
l'una e dalle altre hanno tutto un hanno
tutte uno scopo in comune che è quello
di avanzare nel Progresso imparando
dalla saggezza della natura e nel mentre
guarendo noi stessi e la nostra casa La
terra è Infatti finita l'epoca dove noi
specie umana ci accontentavo solo di
osservare la natura di guardarla di
contemplarne la bellezza o la bruttezza
ma a seconda di canoni che avevamo
deciso noi è giunto il momento di
guardare la natura con spirito critico e
di sviluppare empatia nei suoi confronti
capire che non c'è una differenza
sostanziale tra quello che cercano di
fare loro e quello che facciamo noi
siamo tutti esseri viventi ma ogni
essere vivente vive a modo suo
restiamo quindi in contatto con questi
modelli incredibili con questi geni
naturali che sono arrivati Ben prima di
noi su questa terra e che ci mostrano
come i migliori le migliori idee o i
migliori design potrebbero non essere i
nostri potrebbero essere già stati
inventati e forse così capiremo davvero
come vivere su questa terra in questo
paradiso che noi chiamiamo casa nostra
ma che non è solo nostra la condividiamo
Grazie
mille